well i thought it was time to do another
review of a popular
rap song uh a real banger you might even
say uh and this one just dropped
it's it's that new it's uh nba young boy
around i'm not actually sure where the
rapper's name begins and ends
here um but we'll just call him young
boy for short in any case and i have to
say i'm a little worried
that he's taking a stage name that sort
of puts a time limit on things you know
he can't be 46 years old
and still called young boy um it's kind
of like i was worried back in the 90s
when lil wayne first came on the scene
that if he has a growth spurt
he'd have to change the name fortunately
he never did so
that kind of worked out anyway let's get
to the song this is uh
nba young boy around and let's uh let's
watch it together
[Music]
[Music]
okay just quickly just got to stop it
here i have to say and listen
i i i fully fully admit
and accept that young boy is way cooler
than me orders of magnitude you know but
i just i wonder about this dance move
he's doing this what what what what does
this mean
this means nothing and and this is a and
there's no way that this is okay
this you can't go to the club and do
this i've never been to a club
but i'm pretty sure if i'm at the club
doing this i'd get shot that's that's
the assumption i make
uh and so i'm concerned now i'm
concerned about young boy he looks like
a large flightless bird
um or an escaped mental patient and i'm
concerned that young boy will keep
dancing like this
and and no one will tell him to stop and
so i'm worried about him
now that's that's the feeling that i
have but let's uh let's get back to the
song so i didn't let me hear you
say my name
[Music]
now she wanna make me a man
[Music]
okay i got to stop it again um
and i'm sorry to keep focusing on these
kinds of details but
if we look at the freeze frame here i'm
confused a little bit about what's going
on here
you've got young boy in his garage with
a nice car okay i get that
and if i had a car like that i'd spend a
lot of time in my garage too
no question and he's in a swing
all right he put up a swing in his
garage
no problem there's a little weird but
fine but
what's happening with the couch in the
back it looks like an all-white couch
that someone's scribbled all over um
it looks like my couch is at home
honestly i have four kids
and we actually bought a white couch for
some reason and that's what my kids do
to couches
so have my kids been hanging out with
young boys that's what i'm wondering now
if so that's a problem because
i've told them that they cannot chill in
a rapper's crib and smoke blunts
until they're at least 12 or 13. that's
that's
i don't know how many times i've given
that speech
um anyway let's get back to let's get
let's really get to the meat of this
song now i want to hear what young boy
wants to tell me so i'm going to stop
focusing on the frivolous details let's
listen to the message now
[Music]
[Music]
this is where young boy
is bringing to the surface many of his
deepest
fears and hopes anxieties
exposing his very soul to the world
exposing
so many other things especially with his
pants pulled down that far
so listen to what he says here uh a
check out my fashion
strapped inside my jacket i just said a
prayer for bad bad
say let's go get active geek in when
they cash it
i just love the top down show them the
massive
i pull up freshest i look like a manic
dope inside my coat got me so dumb
that i might need a nanny let's focus on
just those last two lines again because
he says i pull up freshest i look like a
manic dope inside my coat got me so dumb
that i might need a nanny
so there's something almost freudian
going on here i feel like i can tell
that young boy
has been studying some of the early 20th
century psychoanalysts applying their
insights to his own life
here he is yearning for the maternal you
know he says i need a nanny i need a
mother figure a caretaker
uh this world's a great burden for me i
feel
out of place vulnerable yet at the same
time he realizes that he's fresh
you know he's even fresh and and this is
his recognition of his own innocence
and this is really fascinating a young
boy here is exploring the great tension
of youth
um that is the young will cling to their
innocence to their childhood well at the
same time desiring the very freedom
and independence that will lead
ultimately to their corruption
and notice the insecurity too because he
says dope inside my coat
so he what does he say he feels like a
dope when he wears
his coat uh maybe it's it's a few sizes
too big it
doesn't think it looks good is what he's
trying to say and these are the concerns
of youth childlike concerns and maybe
that's what the swing is all about
because the swing and
and the car so you see the disparity
between the desires of youth frivolity
and play
represented by the swing against the
desires of adulthood
materialism greed represented by the car
and behind him yes behind him is the
couch
covered in scribbles and this represents
confusion
it's his it's his internal struggle the
war between the two competing
psychological forces is just stunning
and this is absolutely stunning
um that he's he's gotten this deep
already let's let's keep let's keep
[Music]
[Music]
for a second and tell you about uh my
bookie you know it's betting season at
my booking nothing makes an event or a
game more exciting than putting some
money on it and with the nfl season of
course in full swing it's a great time
to get in on the action sometimes you
have a gut feeling about a match-up
sometimes you're just betting on your
team because they're your team that's
been my strategy maybe not the best one
regardless
whether you've been betting for years or
you're ready to play for the first time
my bookie is your go-to this season head
over to my book you to create an account
just use promo code walsh to claim your
100 deposit match all the way up to a
thousand dollars
that means if you put a hundred dollars
in they'll give you a hundred dollars
and it's an easy way to jump start your
bankroll nfl nba mlb
everything else they've got it all on
tap and it's never too late to start on
your winning season
only at my bookie so let's listen to
these lyrics again
if you didn't catch it the first time
who won a team i got money
i'd be fresh as hell loaded this that
thing
i say baby round and round round and
round shoddy
let me hear you say my name hey i'm rich
plus i'm super lit now she want to make
me all her man
so we confront here again this this
theme of inner turmoil right round and
round
you can hear the pain in his voice but
then he says shoddy let me hear you say
my name so this is ultimately what young
boy wants from the world it's what all
young boys want from the world
to be acknowledged right to be known to
feel his existence validated
by the recognition of others it's a
natural desire it's a common pursuit
but ultimately empty and that's where i
think this will lead in the conclusion
to this epic um i think it's leading
maybe to tragedy let's listen
billy i go whenever i step out i'll
cover my new home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me hear you
[Music]
and we get the guy pointing guns at the
camera i was afraid we wouldn't get that
in this
this video listen to lyrics he says i
try to take off once i face him
in this hablo fit i just changed my name
to double long because
i'm really rich n words on that silly
come to this inside the business killing
and this brings us to the end of the
saga because it is in the end of greek
tragedy which is exactly what i thought
or more reminiscent maybe of 19th
century russian literature
shades of dostoyevsky crime and
punishment young boy playing the role
of of course raskonikov um choosing
corruption in the end you know he
chooses sin he sheds the shell of youth
he breaks free from its innocence
it's purity and suddenly he has no time
he says for that
silly the frivolity and playfulness of
youth he rejects it
um i'm not young boy he says i'm a young
man
but for him to stake his claim in the
world to make his own mark to achieve
the recognition
that he believes he's owed that he
indeed believes he needs
he must descend into brutality inside
the business killing
and again you could tell that young boy
has studied dostoyevsky this is the
beginning of crime and punishment ralph
konokov
kills the old woman kills her to be free
but he finds himself instead
locked in a prison of guilt because he
can't escape his own
moral sins he cannot be the amoral
heathen he wants to be
so young boy here with this jam is
giving us the prelude there's a whole
story
still left to be told a chance even for
a happy ending ultimately
but that's a story for another day one
yet to be told
stay tuned i know i will young boy has
announced himself as another of our
generation's great poets
a man who stands beside the greats you
know edgar allen poe
walt whitman takashi 6'9
i can't wait to hear the next story he
[Music]
tells